they're stateless impoverished and
victims of ongoing human rights abuses
but how much do you know about the RO
hanga of Myanmar
I'm Dina to Korea and here's a look at
one of the world's most persecuted
minorities Myanmar the country formerly
known as Burma was long considered a
pariah state ruled by a military junta
but in 2011 half a century military rule
came to an end with democratic elections
but democracy hasn't brought universal
freedom to all the people of Myanmar and
in Rakhine State the rise of a militant
branch of Buddhist nationalists has
sparked what human rights watch has
called an ethnic cleansing against the
minority Muslim population Myanmar is at
a geographic crossroad between China and
India it also shares borders with
Bangladesh Laos and Thailand which means
it has long been ethnically diverse in
fact the country recognizes 134 ethnic
groups but refuses to consider the 1.3
million Rohan go one of them even though
they've lived in Myanmar for centuries
and call it their homeland in 1982 a law
was passed that denied them citizenship
formally they can't travel or get
married without permission they can't
own land and some of them are forbidden
from having more than two children
recently in 2014 they were excluded from
the country's first census in 30 years -
the majority of the country they're
merely squatters who illegally
immigrated from Bangladesh over the past
two years long simmering tensions
erupted with RO hanga coming under
attack by mobs of Buddhist nationalists
who claimed that they are protecting the
country against a Muslim invasion it's
Myanmar's worst bloodshed in generations
with RO hanga being burned out of their
homes and held in de facto open air
hundreds have died in various massacres
fearful for their lives several hundred
thousand rohesia have had no choice but
to flee here's how one row Ganga refugee
who fled Myanmar described it
being stateless and displaced makes them
vulnerable to human traffickers who
often extort money to get them across
borders men get sold into indentured
slavery and women are sold as brides
hundreds died at sea when their ships
capsized Myanmar is basically throwing
its international legitimacy in question
through its treatment of its most
vulnerable minority the violence against
the RO hanga has also become a challenge
for Nobel Peace Prize winner on sang-soo
Chi's image as a unifying moral force
she's a devout Buddhist and now
opposition leader in Parliament but this
is what she had to say about the ROA
hinga no no it's not ethnic cleansing
it's a it's a new problem and yet it's
linked to old problems as well so now
that you know a bit more about the RO
hanga people's plight how do you think
the international community should act